monsieur charon
merci monsieur le président monsieur
ministre messieurs le rapporte mehr
chers collègues
cet article 84 terre introduit par
amendement sénatorial
supprimée par l'assemblée nationale
traite en réalité d'une question assez
éloignées comme ça a été ré rappelé
plusieurs fois tu logements à des
procédures d'urbanisme
ces deux amendements qui viennent de
nous être présentés ne me paraissent
toujours pas devoir être adoptées par
notre assemblée
si j'ai comme beaucoup d'entre nous
comme les rapporteurs l'an l'on dit tout
à l'heure de la sympathie pour la
défense des communes rurales est un
natif du loir et cher
il me semble pas raisonnable de prendre
le cas très particulier de chambord pour
en faire un cas général sur les pouvoirs
du maire en france en effet comme vous
le savez chambord est le seul cas en
france où le territoire communal est
entièrement propriété de l'état ce qui
n'avait pas posé de problème jusqu'ici à
la commune sous la iiième cela quatrième
sous la vème république en tant
qu'ancien président du conseil
d'administration du domaine national de
chambord je ne peux me rallier aux
dispositions proposées tant elles vont à
l'encontre de l'intérêt général je vois
pour ma part au moins quatre raisons
auxquelles seraient sensibles notre
commission des lois il s'agit d'abord à
l'évidence d'un cavalier législatif
susceptibles d'être censurée par le
conseil constitutionnel c'est d'ailleurs
l'un dés motifs de rejet de l'amendement
par la commission des affaires
économiques la question a déjà été
tranché au fond par le conseil d'état en
décembre 2011 lors d'une question
prioritaire de constitutionnalité qui
avait été précisément posée par le maire
de chambord la commune estimait que la
création d'un établissement public
porter atteinte à l'article 72 de la
constitution
or le conseil d'état a conclu au nom du
peuple français que la question n'était
pas nouvelle et ne présentait pas un
caractère sérieux dès lors on ne voit
pas ce qu'ajoute ces amendements sinon
une confusion juridique dans la
répartition des pouvoirs entre la
commune et l'établissement public car la
loi de février 2005 créant
l'établissement public industriel et
commercial
c'est bien un epic dont il s'agit a bien
conférer à celui ci un certain nombre de
pouvoirs comme la gestion des voies de
circulation hors agglomération cette
confusion juridique risque donc de
relancer des contentieux inutile et
contrairement à ce que soutient la
motivation d'amendements il n'est pas
exact que le maire de chambord dispose
des mêmes compétences que n'importe quel
maire de france il ne le peut pas par
construction puisque ne dispose pas de
domaine public communal le choix du
législateur a toujours été jusqu'ici de
préserver l'intégrité d'un domaine
national dans les mains de l'état au nom
de l'intérêt général
c'est en ce sens d'ailleurs que le
gouvernement s'apprête dans son projet
de loi sur le patrimoine à rendre il y à
l'ena inaliénable pardon les grands
domaines nationaux à l'instar des
collections publiques qui garnissent nos
musées les amendements qui nous sont
présentés qui prévoit dans le deuxième
paragraphe une convention de mise à
disposition à la commune de bien
évidemment les essais au service public
communal sont doublement inutile la base
légale existe déjà pour une telle
convention et l'offre a déjà été fait à
la commune en tout état de cause on ne
voit pas quelle serait la portée
générale de ces amendements il ne me
semble pas que le parlement doivent
servir à régler par la loi des problèmes
d'opportunités des arrangements de
personnes ou au cas par cas les affaires
de 36000 communes de france je
souhaiterais mal un gourou en conclusion
prendre un peu de hauteur de vue à
partir de cet exemple sur l'organisation
de nos structures territoriales
à l'assemblée nationale le député de la
circonscription
monsieur patrice martin-lalande a
suggéré d'examiner la fusion de la
commune de chambord 150 habitants avec
celle de saint dié 600 habitants qui est
l'ancien port de chambord de sorte que
le domaine national de chambord se
trouve comme les domaines nationaux de
versailles fontainebleau et compiègne
inséré dans une commune plus large tu ne
poserai dès lors plus les mêmes
questions existentielles dans sa
conférence de presse du 14 janvier le
président de la république n'at-il pas
déclaré que notre organisation
territoriale devaient être revus et les
collectivités locales inciter à se
rapprocher hors la loi de 2005 place
chambord sous la haute protection du
président de la république grâce à un
amendement charasse d'ailleurs
il n'aura non pas douter hackers
d'appuyer un projet de fusion de
communes de chambord et de saint dié
propositions qu'ils rencontrent
d'ailleurs une large adhésion locales
selon les échos que j'en ai c'est une
solution logique courageuse qui
s'inscrit dans la voie de la
simplification des différentes strates
des institutions locales et qui
influencent directement l'organisation
des acteurs touristiques public c'est
une solution nom de l'intérêt général
qui préserverait le bon usage de la
dotation globale de fonctionnement
plutôt que d'alimenter les contentieux
locaux de la commune de chambord je vous
invite donc mes chers collègues a rejeté
ces amendements et à maintenir la
suppression de cet article merci merci
monsieur charon